MIKE AIZATSKYI: Good
afternoon, ladies and gentlemen.
I'm really excited to
see you here today.
I'm Mike Aizatskyi from App
Engine Engineering Team.
And today we would like to talk
to you about App Engine
and MapReduce.
So the agenda of today's talk
is to go briefly through
MapReduce Computational Model,
because I assume some of you
would like another reminder
of what it is.
Then we'll remember the Mapper
library, which we've now
released like a year ago with
previous Google I/O.
Then I'll make a couple
announcements.
I'm going to talk about some
technical stuff to get you
interested in how we did some
things in App Engine Team.
And throughout the whole
presentation, I'm going to
show you several examples and
demos just to keep you
entertained.
So let's start with MapReduce
Computational Model.
You might know that MapReduce
was created at Google many
years ago to solve
problems with
efficient distributed computing.
And really, absolutely
every team uses
MapReduce for something.
I'm absolutely sure that even
Android team uses MapReduce
for doing some stuff, for
doing some population
statistics, whatever.
And it's been a real success at
Google, and we use it for
everything.
And this is a diagram of
how it looks like.
It might be a little bit
confusing, so we'll go through
it step by step.
But it basically has three major
steps, and those are
called map, shuffle,
and reduce.
So the map shuffle is some kind
of user code which runs
over input data.
That input data might be
database, some files, whatever.
And the goal of the code is to
output key and value pairs.
And the MapReduce framework
should take those key value
pairs and should store
them somewhere for
other steps to consume.
And as you see, the input is
usually sharded, like split in
parts, so that all of them can
be processed and paralleled
really, really fast. And as
I said, this is user code.
The second step of MapReduce
is a shuffle step.
And the shuffle phase has to
collate values with the same
key together.
It has to go through all
the values which are
generated by map phase.
It should find similar,
same keys.
It should bundle those values
together, and it should output
key and list of value pairs.
And this step has no user
code whatsoever.
This is a generic step of
web-produced framework,
provided usually as some kind
of service, as some kind of
magic black box which
does shuffle.
And the third part is reduce.
And the reduce function will
actually take the shuffle
output, which is the key, and
list of value pairs, and it
does something with that.
It might compute something more
interesting from that data.
It might save it to database.
It might do something.
And this is again
the user code.
And again, it's goal is to
process the shuffle output as
fast as possible, and it's
good if it's parallel.
So once again, this is the
diagram of MapReduce
Computational Model, not
the implementation
but just the model.
So we have map step, key values,
shuffle bundles same
keys together, and reduce,
process, and shuffle output.
So the way we work at App
Engine, we usually take
something which we already have
at Google and which works
for Google, which works for
us, and we give it to you.
We give it to our developers.
We bundle it somehow, and we
give you access to that same
set of technologies.
And this is exactly what we
wanted to do with MapReduce.
But when we started working in
that, we realized that there
are lots of problems
with this approach,
unique to the App Engine.
First of all, App Engine has
scaling dimensions which we
usually don't have at Google.
App Engine has lots and lots
of applications, much more
than Google applications.
And we expect many of them that
will run MapReduce at the
same time, and that might cause
additional scalability
problems.
The other problem
is isolation.
We do not want anyone running
something to kill a royal
wedding website.
If you run MapReduce, you want
royal wedding to be up.
So we want to completely isolate
all applications from
each other, but still we want
them to have good performance.
It might be surprising, but we
also want to rate limit.
Originally, MapReduce at Google
was designed to go as
fast as possible.
It wants to process all the
data in shortest amount of
time possible.
And that means that we can
consume thousands of dollars
resources per minute.
And not everyone is happy about
that, because you might
run MapReduce and it will
consume all your daily
resources in 15 minutes.
It will kill your online
traffic, so you might want to
rate limit it and say, OK, don't
run in five minutes.
Please run over two hours,
because I have short-term
quotas which I don't
want to consume.
And taken to the extreme, there
are even three apps
which have a very, very limited
amount of quotas, and
they still want to
run MapReduces.
And they might say, OK, run this
for the whole week, but
just get it done.
But please, please, please do
not kill my application, which
is not a goal for MapReduce,
Google's MapReduce to run as
slow as possible.
We also have a protection issue,
too, because there a
lots of users out there.
Some of them are malicious.
Some of them are just not
doing the right thing.
And we want everyone to protect
from each other.
We want to protect
Google from you.
We want to protect you from
each other, so that nobody
steals over there.
So when we analyzed all this,
we realized that it's not a
really good idea to take the
Google's MapReduce and give it
to you as is.
We realized that we need
to do lots and lots
of additional work.
And that's why, a year ago, we
released the Mapper Library,
which implemented the first
step of MapReduce,
which is map phase.
We released it at Google I/O
2010, in this building.
Since then, it's been heavily
used by developers everywhere,
outside, inside Google.
We even use it in
App Engine Team.
We use it in admin console.
We generate reports with that.
We have new index pipeline,
which is in the works, which
uses Mapper Library.
And lots of people-- like, there
was recently a blog post
about guys using
Mapper Library,
which is already useful.
And during the whole year,
we've been working on
improving that.
And they had quite
a lot of set of
improvements to the library.
Let me go through
some of them.
We have Control API, so that
you can programatically
control your jobs.
So that you can, for example,
create a cron job, which will
run everyday and start Mapper.
We have custom mutation pools,
which is the way to batch some
work within map function calls
and process it more
efficiently.
We have namespaces support, so
that normally you can run your
Mapper over some fixed
namespace, if you use
namespace, or some several
namespaces.
You can even run Mappers over
namespaces, not the data
inside namespaces but just over
namespaces, so that you
can analyze your namespaces.
You can do some kind of
migration, statistics, whatever.
We have implemented better
sharding with scatter indices.
So they think sharding
is now pretty good.
And there are many more small
improvements to the library.
So if we take a look at this,
and we ask a question, what
should we do to take
Mapper Library to
the MapReduce Library?
The first thing is we need
some kind of storage for
intermediate data, because map
jobs, they tend to output lots
and lots of data
in MapReducers.
And for that one, we designed
the Files API, which we'll go
through in more detail later.
And we released it in March
2011, just two months ago.
We also have to implement
the shuffler service.
And reducer is not a problem,
because reducer is actually
the mapper.
It just goes over
shuffle output.
And of course, we have
to write lots and
lots of glue code.
So today, I'm happy to say
that we're launching the
shuffler functionality.
And this actually has two
different functionalities.
First of all, we have a full
in-memory user space,
task-driven open source shuffler
for kind of small
data stats.
And small, I mean like, hundreds
of megabytes, maybe
gigabytes, maybe even more.
Who knows?
This is completely open
source for Python.
Java comes soon.
It will be open source, too.
We also announced that we want
to start trusted testers
access to big shuffler.
So if you have some kind of data
set, which you need to
run MapReducer on, and you have
hundreds of gigabytes of
data and you want to run
MapReducer, just get in touch
with us and we will see how
we can work for you.
And we also, of course, written
all the integration
pieces which are needed to
run your MapReduce jobs.
And they are part of Mapper
Library, which we are now
deciding to call MapReduce
Library.
It's not a map library
anymore.
So without going--
we'll go to the technical
details later.
But first, let's go through some
simple examples of how
MapReducers look like.
And the first really simple
example, which is the, hello
world, of MapReduce, is a
word count MapReduce.
And the goal of MapReduce is to
take some set of text, some
text, and calculate how many
times a single word appears in
the text, like basically
statistics of distributions.
And map function is
really simple.
It's almost like, two lines,
even if you throw in some
additional declarations.
Basically you split the text in
words, and your yield word
is the key and empty
screen is values.
We're not using values
here, per se.
We're just going to need
them to count those.
So if you take the famous quote
from the Pulp Fiction,
then for five words, we can
output five key value pairs.
Then the shuffler will take this
data, will process it,
and then will bundle
all values for
the same keys together.
So we'll have three
pairs that maybe--
that are going to have all two
values from the input, which
are empty screens
that also two.
And baby's going to
have only one.
And reduce phase just
ignores values.
It just counts how many
of those there are.
So it's going to output
Zed's two times.
Dead is two times.
And baby is one time.
So let's see how this works.
Is it large enough?
So unfortunately, this stuff
runs for several minutes in
the data set that they
chose, so I decided
not to run it directly.
And I took 90 books,
90-something books from
Gutenberg Project, which
amounts to tens of
megabytes of text.
And I run this MapReduce.
It took six minutes.
And you can see that
this is our new UI
for multi-stage processes.
We're going to talk abut about
this with it later.
But you can see that the whole
MapReduce count took, like,
six minutes, 40 seconds.
Map phase took one minute,
40 seconds.
Shuffle took three minutes.
And reduce took one minute,
50 seconds.
And there were some additional
steps, like cleanup and some
statistics steps.
And if you take a reduce
job, which has
finished in a minute--
here it is one minute, 50
seconds-- we can see that it
read 78 gigabytes of
intermediate data, which is
quite good.
I'm told that shuffler is
supposed to process hundreds
of megabytes, but we're actually
being run to being
able to run it like over 78
gigabytes without big
problems. The output--
how much?
One gigabyte of data.
And the total input
size was just--
the input size, we have, like,
50 megabytes of text, books.
This is how its output
looks like.
So we have all the words,
which are in some order.
They're kind of sorted, but
we'll talk about this later.
But we can see that captivity,
or like, I don't know what it
is, but it's actually
present only once.
So if we use some kind of graph,
with this word, we can
see that it actually happens
only once, in this only book.
And yeah, it works.
So this is the word
count MapReduce.
And now let's improve our word
count MapReduce to build the
simplest possible, really useful
MapReduce, which is a
building block for, even
for google.com.
And this MapReduce is called
building inverse index, which
means that we want to build a
huge map which allows you to
look up which documents
have a given word.
And you can actually say
that this is how
Google Count works.
So if you have internet on your
CD-ROM and you upload it
to App Engine, then you
can build the Google
Count search index.
So we use the same stuff, but
instead of ignoring file name,
instead of outputting empty
screens, we'll output the file
name, or document name, or
something which identifies
where this word comes from.
And the only thing we do in
reduce, we just remove
duplicate values.
We just built the list that this
word is going to occurs
in this document, this document,
and this document.
Of course, instead of just
duplicating documents, you can
calculate how many times
it occurs in documents.
So later you can compute some
kind of ranking, whatever.
But this is the simplest one.
Again, I'm going to show you
that it's actually ran a
little bit slower
for some reason.
It's undetermined
minutes of time.
But yeah, it took six
minutes, 50 seconds.
If you take a look at the size
of intermediate data--
here it is.
We can see that we actually
processed 170 gigabytes of
intermediate data.
And the whole MapReduce took six
minutes, which we think is
actually quite good.
So here is how the output looks
like for the whole 60
megabytes of books from
Gutenberg Project.
So you can pick--
now you can get this document.
And you can actually build a
web storage, which has some
kind of search here.
So let's verify that it works.
Let's take a look at aviators.
Here it is--
want to see aviators,
everything.
You can actually see that there
are only two documents
which have this word, 1059
and 3061, which is true.
So I'm quite confident
that it works.
So these were two most common
and the simplest MapReducers
you could write.
Later in this talk, I'll show
you a little bit more
complicated and interesting
MapReduce.
But now I would like
to dive into
technical bits of our solutions.
I'd like to talk about how
we did what we did.
And actually I would like to
show you that you could build
something, or you can build
something, similar or modified
to your needs, now that
you know how it works.
And I'm going to talk
about two things.
I'm going to talk about Files
API, which was our solution to
MapReduce storage problem.
And I'm going to talk about
User-Space Shuffler, about how
we built it, which algorithm
did we use,
and so on, so forth.
So Files API.
As I told you, and as you have
seen, MapReduce jobs generate
lots of intermediate data.
This was a tiny, simple
MapReduce, which is just an
example, and processes just 60
megabytes of input data.
And it generated 170 gigabytes
of intermediate data.
And of course, you have
to store it somewhere.
So before Files API, we had
three storage systems. We had
Data Store, which is kind of
expensive because it's
replicated over the multiple
data centers, lots of copies.
And it also has one megabyte
entity limit, which makes
storing 170 gigabytes of
data kind of hard.
You have to split it.
You have to remember where
you put its chunk.
You have to read it in order.
It's not a pleasant task.
We also had a blobstore,
which is really
good, but it's redundant.
The only way you could get
data in, you could upload
files through a CPU
form, which does
not work for MapReduce.
And you had Memcache.
Memcache is kind of good.
It's really fast, but it's small
and it's not reliable.
You can never be sure that the
data you put in is still
there, because there might
be memory pressure
or something else.
So that's why we designed
the Files API.
We wanted to give you familiar
files-like interface to some
kind of virtual file systems.
These are not local files.
These are virtual file
systems. They
look like local files.
If you have ever accessed local
files, you will find it
similar to you.
We released it in 1.4.3.
We integrate it with Mapper
Library the way I'm
going to show you.
And we kind of consider it
to be a low-level API.
It's not something that
every user, we
think, is going to need.
Most users will probably just
use MapReduce Library.
But you might find some
interesting needs
for this one, too.
And it's also still an
experimental library,
experimental API.
We're still looking
at how it works.
We're still trying to
understand what you
need, what we need.
And these files--
I said that the API is really
familiar to local file
systems. But it has some
huge differences.
Basically, the biggest
difference here is that files
have to stay writable
and readable.
In writable state, you can
write the file but
you cannot read it.
In readable state, you
can read but you
cannot write to it.
And all files start
in writable.
Later, when you're done writing,
you can finalize the
file, and you can transfer
it to readable state.
There is no way out
of readable state.
Once it's finalized,
it's forever.
All writes are append-only, so
there is no random access.
All writes are atomic, meaning
that if you output 100 bytes,
then nothing is going to get
in between of those.
And they are fully serializable
between
concurrent clients, meaning that
you might have lots of
big round tasks, lots of tasking
tasks tasked right
into the same file at the same
time and we're going to make
sure that all the data does not
interweave between them.
And they also say that some
concrete file systems, they
might have some additional APIs
for dealing with their
own properties.
And every file system is going
to have their own reliability,
or like volubility constraints
or guarantees.
Files API doesn't
know about that.
In March, we'll release
the first file system.
This is a blobstore
filesystem.
So we actually took the
read-only blobstore facility
and we made it writable.
So you can now write directly
to blobstore.
You can create really
huge files.
There is no limitation aside
64-bit plans, which I think is
going to be enough for the
next thousand years.
Once you finalize the file,
those files are fully durable.
They're going to be replicated
across multiple data centers.
And they're going to have the
same reliability guarantees as
high-replication data store.
But the important point here is
that writable files are not
durable, meaning that if
something bad happens, for
example, we have data store
failure, or we might have a
maintenance period.
So you might lose
your files while
they're in writable state.
It is especially so that while
you write, we don't replicate
it, so that [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
is good.
Because they think that
MapReduce is going to be the
primary consumer of this API.
OK.
If something bad has happened,
you're going to restart
MapReduce jobs.
And since this is blobstore, you
can fetch a blob key for
finalized file and use the
familiar blobstore API.
So if you want to download that
file or serve it to the
user, you could get the blob key
and serve it directly to
the user without writing
too many code.
This way you can create a, I
don't know, you can write a
code which generates
some kind of movie.
You just write the blobstore
frame by frame, then you
finalize it, and you
can serve it.
This is a simple Python example
of how you could
access it if Java
has its own API.
And yeah, we don't have much
time to go through all of
those, but basically it looks
familiar to the language.
It's mostly like the files
you have in Python.
So first of all, you create
the files in blobstore.
And you specifically say, OK, I
want a file from blobstore.
Then you open it to write.
You write data.
And once you're done, you say,
OK, finalize the file.
To read it, it's
the same stuff.
You can open file.
You can read from it.
You can seek in the file.
Write is append-only, and read
can have random access.
So you can do lots of crazy,
interesting things.
And if you want to get blob key,
you just call, get blob
key function, and you're going
to get a blob key for filing.
As I said, we integrate
with Mapper Library.
We edit some kind of output
writers support.
So there's one line
in MapReduce.
It's [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
It would just specify, OK, I
want the output of this Mapper
function to go directly
to blobstore.
This way, by having single-line
map function, we
just confirm send it to the csv
line, or xml, whatever you
can-- you can easily write a
mapper which will export your
data into blobstore.
And since you have control API,
you can actually create a
cron job, and do a copy of your
data every day, or every
week, or run it whenever
you need.
We also plan to migrate, both
download it and upload it this
functionality.
We're not there yet, but it
will eventually come.
But meanwhile, it's now easy to
get the data in some sort
of downloadable format.
And we also have some low-level
features, which
we're not going to spend lots
of time, but basically have
exclusive locks.
You can lock files.
You can make sure that no
one else accesses it.
And we have sequence keys, so
that if you need some kind of
guarantee that you have written
the data you're
already writing, because request
might be retried,
possibly might be rerun, or
request might come the second
time from the user.
That there is some notion of
sequence key and the API will
take care of you.
If you need this, read the API
documentation and source code.
And in the future, we're going
to introduce more file
systems. The first one which we
really, really want to get
out, we call it Tempfile
system.
This is going to be much faster,
much cheaper, because
it's not going to replicated
anywhere.
But it's not going to
be durable at all,
even finalized files.
It might lose those if something
bad happens.
And you're going to have each
file be stored only for
several days, because we want
this to be a MapReduce banking
file system.
We want it to be really fast. We
want it to be able to store
terabytes there without
selling your house.
Another thing is that we want
to integrate with other
storage technologies, which
we got at Google.
Yeah, just keep looking at
we're doing and we have--
we're going to have lots of
exciting file systems coming.
So this was Files API.
And now let's talk about the
bread and butter of our
MapReduce implementation, which
is User-Space Shuffler.
So as I told you, we're going
to have two shufflers: the
User-Space, which is kind of
simple, open source, and it
has its limits on the data it
can process; and we're going
to have a huge shuffler service,
which is hidden,
which is just an API code which
says, OK, shuffle this
for me, and is going to process
lots and lots of data
really, really quickly.
But we wanted to have User-Space
Shuffler for small
and medium jobs.
And as you remember, the job
of the shuffler is to
consolidate values for the
same key together.
So look around the data,
find those same
keys, values together.
And even that we want to have
this User-Space Shuffler,
meaning it is in full
source code.
It has no new App Engine
components.
Anyone could have built
something like that
We still want it to be
reasonably fast, reasonably
scalable, and reasonably
efficient.
Because we just saw that,
yeah, 170 gigabyte
is not a big deal.
It's just a couple minutes,
which is good.
So the way we're going
to arrive at shuffler
implementation is we're going
to start with really, really
stupid shuffler.
We're going to improve it step
by step until we get to the
file algorithm.
And the first inaugural
shuffler is just load
everything to memory, sort it.
And read the sorted array.
This is going to
look like this.
Once you have your values sorted
by key, you can just
read and see, OK, this is the
same key, grab this value.
Same key, grab this value.
OK, this is another key.
Here are your values.
It's really just a couple
lines of code, but
unfortunately, it has
lots of problems.
First of all, it's memory-bound
algorithm, by how
much data you can
fit in memory.
Like, if you're having a
separate workstation, like
server, computer, you might be
lucky to have 64 gigabytes.
So it's actually memory-bound,
and there is no way to
increase performance by throwing
more resources into
it, because it's
single-thread.
It's just sorted, no
way out of it.
So we're going to improve this
one by chunking our input data
into chunks, and store the
data into Files API.
And then each chunk will be
sorted by its own. so those
chunks should be of some size,
because when you're writing in
App Engine, in Python, it's not
really memory-efficient,
our chunk size is
like five megs.
So we're going to sort each one
of those, store it, and
then we're going to merge stored
all chunks together
using external merge.
Or even as MapReduce Library
does, we're just going to
merge-read without
sorting, just
merge-read from all of those.
This is really simple.
Your upper two blobs go to the
first chunks, lower three to
the second chunk.
And then you're going to
merge-read by maintaining
pointers into each
one of those.
You read from all of them.
You see, OK, blue,
blue, blue, blue.
Then you move each
one of them.
And yeah, it's going to work.
And the properties of this
approach is that first of all,
this is no longer
memory-bound.
You can sort as many chunks as
you want, as soon as each one
of those fit in memory.
Another good thing that this
sorting is parallel.
You can throw in thousand
computers, give each one a
chunk, and they're going
to finish in parallel.
But unfortunately, the
merge phase, merge
phase is not parallel.
It's just one phase in a single
computer, which has to
merge-read all of them.
It is kind of difficult and slow
to merge-read from too
many files, like you could
have 10,000s of files, it
should have some kind of heap
structure to maintain pointers
into 10,000s of files.
Yeah, it's getting really,
really slow once you crank up
number of files.
So we're going to improve
this, too.
And the way we're going to
improve it is we're going to
use the hash code of the key.
So it's really like, if hash
codes of the key is divisible
by two and not divisible by two,
then we can process all
those keys, two keys,
separately.
Like, all even keys
go into one chunk.
All odd keys go to
another chunk.
And we can run the same
algorithm from the previous
step on all those
chunks together.
We don't have to worry about
merge-reading all of them,
because each one of them has
different hash keys.
This is how it's
going to look.
It looks quite nice, you know.
And then I needed
a fourth color.
But basically once again, we
take a look at each block
output from Mapper.
We separate it into chunks
by hash code.
Like, blue and red goes to the
top, green and yellow goes to
the bottom.
Then, we sort data from
each hash chunk.
So we sort some greens
and yellows.
We sort some blues and greens.
And then we're going
to do a merge-read
from only those chunks.
And this approach is actually
quite good.
Because by having hash code, you
can split your output data
into as many hash code-based
chunks as you want.
You want thousands?
You got it.
You want 10,000?
So you can have, merge, as
parallel as possible.
You can run thousands of
merge-reads in parallel.
All sorting is in parallel.
There is no memory-bound
thing here.
If you have to read too many
data, just increase number of
hash chunks and process
them separately.
And this is actually the
shuffler, which we released
today for Python.
And the Java version is going
to come really, really soon.
As far as I know, even someone
is working on that.
Yeah, this was the shuffler.
This is the way it works.
Of course, the goal is more
complicated than that, because
we have to deal with lots
of tiny details.
But this is the idea.
And we soon realized that our
MapReducer consisted of
several offline processes
like map.
You have to finish map before
you start shuffle.
Shuffle, you have to
finish shuffle
before you start reduce.
So we designed a new API to
chain complex works together,
and we called it the
Pipeline API.
And this is actually the glue
which holds the Mapper,
Shuffler, and Reducer, and
which makes it a single
MapReduce job.
And our MapReduce Library
is now fully
integrated with Pipeline.
And that UI which you saw was
multiple stages that actually
come from Pipeline API.
It's an API which takes care of
all that detail, that, OK,
after you're done with user, you
have to run cleanup jobs
to clean up all those
intermediate files.
This is the API which
enables to do that.
And if you're interested in this
API, I want to emphasize
the talk of my colleague,
Brett Slatkin.
It's called "Large Scale Data
Analysis Using the App Engine
Pipeline API." I think
it's 4:00 something.
So yeah, please come in if
you're interested in running
your own complex processes.
And now, I promised you a more
complicated, more involving
example of MapReducer.
And the examples, we're going
to write is which I call
distinguishing phrases.
So the idea is to take a look
at multiple books and figure
out if some phrase has been used
in one particular book a
lot, but not used in
the other books.
Like, if some authors have their
own signature phrases,
or some books have signature
phrases.
The way we're going to do it
is we're going to split the
text into ngrams. ngrams
is a sequence of n
consequent words together.
And you can pick the n which
you like, so I ran the
examples for n equals 4.
The problem here, if you
increase n a lot, like if you
use 10 grams, then 10 grams
are probably quite unique
because these are complete
sentences already.
And they're quite unique.
And if you use n equals 2, this
is not even a phrase.
This is just two words.
So I picked 4.
And for its use, the first thing
we're going to do, we're
going to check if this phrase
is actually frequent.
We're not interested
in something the
author used only once.
So we check if it occurred
10 times.
Then we're going to check if a
single author or a single book
has this phrase more than every
other book combined,
which means that this is really
unique for this book
because it's more than
everyone else.
And we're going to run
this on the same data
set, which is 90 books.
Let me show you how it went.
So it took like, seven
minutes or something.
This is, as I told,
the UI which comes
from Pipeline library.
So we have map, line,
shuffle, reduce.
If you actually open the
shuffle, you can see that
there are lots of
sort pipelines.
And each sort pipeline, is
certain one hash based bucket
the way I explained to you.
And yeah, so it finished
in like,
seven minutes, 25 seconds.
Just to have an idea of if this
seven minutes is good or
not, I wrote a simple Python
program, which uses the same
MapReduce Computational Model,
but completely in-memory in a
single computer, and in one
thread, because it's Python.
And on my computer, it
took like, almost
20 minutes to complete.
So this already faster than
writing in computer.
And this actually scales, so if
you increase the data set,
you could just increase number
of shards, and you're not
supposed to see a huge
time increase.
And when I was creating this
demo, I wasn't even sure that
this was going to work, but it
turns out there are lots and
lots of unique phrases
in books.
And this is the output.
There are lots and lots
of phrases here
which you could use.
Here it is.
Money price of corn.
Let's just check.
Oh, this is not fair.
This is just one book which
always talks about
money price of corn.
Let's pick something else.
This is Spanish.
Yeah, these are the same.
It's surprising that this
is unique, right?
Yeah, so you can see that there
were three books which
use the phrase only once.
"These are the same"
something.
And there is one book which
used it seven times.
And I'm just curious,
this is the--
what is this?
This is an old book of
Leonardo da Vinci.
So you can say that in this book
set, the use of the same
phrase, kind of uniquely
identifies Leonardo da Vinci.
If you have a huge corpus of
text, I guess it might become
really interesting.
And this was all like--
if you throw in all the details
which I omitted here,
like count occurrences in line
of functions, it's like 50
lines of code.
It's not a big deal, and it's
really something interesting.
So this was all I wanted to talk
to you about today, and
let me summarize what
I was talking about.
So starting today, I did a push
couple hours ago into
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
You can grab the source
code, and you
can take a look examples.
The communication
is coming soon.
And you can run small, medium,
and who knows how big they can
be, these User-Space
Shufflers.
We haven't actually pushed
the limit yet.
You can run those MapReducers
today in Python.
Java's going to come
really soon.
If you're interested in
helping us to get Java
implementation, just write us
an email and we'll tell you
where we need help.
And I know there are already
people helping us.
Right?
Yeah.
And if you're interested in
large MapReducers, like maybe
we should call them huge
MapReducers, get
in touch with us.
We'll give you the API to access
the full-blown shuffler
for certain terabytes of data.
I don't know.
So now I'm ready to answer
any questions
you might have. Thanks.
It looks like magic, but you
know, I didn't quite
understand the shuffle part
and the merge portion.
You know, as a framework,
it looks very complete.
But when you run it on Google
App Engine, you have the task
use which allows
you to do map.
But as far as the merge and the
shuffling is concerned, if
you run it parallel-ly as
different execution threads,
you need to have a common place
where you can do merge.
It can even be a data store,
or it can be memory.
If it's data store, the current
BigTable doesn't allow
you to do a Select
For Update thing.
Which means if you try to
implement the same inventory
from two different threads--
right.
So when you do an update, and
when you read something else,
it gives you dirty
data, right?
MIKE AIZATSKYI: So
basically, yes.
The Pipeline API gives
you some kind of
synchronization point.
It takes care of all
of that by itself.
It knows all the limitations
of App Engine platforms. It
knows that it stores data
in data stores.
It knows that it's bad to access
the same entity from
multiple requests at
the same time.
And Pipeline API hides all
the complexity for you.
It just defines a job as a
simple Python function.
And you say, OK, run it after
this one completes, and pass
all the output here.
And it's going to take
care of that for you.
OK.
Right.
So where do we get--
because we are trying to do this
for aggregate queries,
and you're not able to figure
out a way within the--
MIKE AIZATSKYI: It doesn't use
any kind of aggregate queries.
It uses key names in a
really interesting
fashion to achieve that.
Right.
But key name, you know,
aggregating information is the
objective of merging to
a key name, right?
MIKE AIZATSKYI: Yeah.
For a use case like
aggregate queries.
MIKE AIZATSKYI: Yeah, but just
take a look at source codes.
It's all open source.
Anyone else want
to be on tape?
So then we're done.
Thank you a lot for coming.
If you have any questions which
you want to ask me off
the record, feel free
to come to me.
Thanks a lot.